montré les limites du réseau.
Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau.
s'est écroulé.
- C'était en 2018. Samuel perd
le contrôle de sa vie. Il voit
des images, des souvenirs qui
ne semblent pas lui appartenir.
- Dans le fond, j'
un syndrome de choc post-
traumatique dû estes.
Un contexte incestueux
qui s'est produit
pendant plusieurs années.
- Samuel a eu la force d'aller
chercher de l'aide auprès
D'emphase, un organisme pour les
hommes victimes d'abus sexuel.
Mais les hommes sont encoreide.
- On a des hommes qui ont
esse psychologique
plus grande, mais qui ne vont
pas voir les resso
- En partie parce qu'ils ne
les connaissent pas. Sept hommes
sur dix
où demander de l'aide.
Et lorsqu'ils le font, ils
doivent parfois être patients.
provincial en santé des hommes
- J'ai beaucoup d'organismes qui
peinent à offrir des services
rapides séparation conjugale. Qn
est dans une situation de crises
dans trois mois qu'on a besoin
de services, c'est là. Donc,est-
d'oeuvre est un obstacle,
la connaissance deissance deiss.
- Après les nombreux
féminicides, Québec a dédié
des fonds spécifiquement
conjugale, ce qui a fait fondre
les délais d'attente.
GENEVIÈVE LANDRY,
présidente, À coeur d'homme
- Dans certaines régions,x
semaines d'attente, donc on est
très coça.
- Mais si ce n'est pas dans un
contexte de violence, il faut
public, 19 000 personnes
t toujours des soins
psychologiques.
- Un des enjeux, c'est que
- Pierre- Pierre- Pierre- Pierré
pendant 42 ans dans le réseau
de la santé. Il croit que
le système est mal outillé
dits traditionnels.PIERRE L'HEU,
ex-intervenant en santé mentale
leur réalité et leur réalité en
relation. Et parfois, ils ontttt
de la difficulté même à mettre
des mots sur ce qui se passe
- Pour mieux répondre à leurs
besoins, il faut f
le personnel, majoritairement
féminin.
- Que les intervenantes
et les intervenants soient mieux
préparés à recev la difficulté r
leurs besoins, ayant de la
difficulté à aborder les enjeux
émotionnels et relationnels.
- Samuel, lui, apprend
à vivre avec sa sensibilité,aves
puissent suivre ses pas.
- Vous manquez vraiment une
place au soleil. Ça change ta
vie. Moi, ça a changé ma vie.
- Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montré